[APPLAUSE]
ALAN PRICE: Good evening.
AUDIENCE: Good evening.
ALAN PRICE: I'm Alan Price.
I'm Director here at the
John F. Kennedy Presidential
Library and Museum, and
it's good to see you here.
Many of you, I'm
seeing you again.
So welcome back.
On behalf of my colleague
Steven Rothstein at the Kennedy
Library Foundation, and all
my Library and Foundation
colleagues, I thank you
for coming this evening.
I would like to acknowledge
the generous support
of our underwriters of the
Kennedy Library Forums,
lead sponsors, Bank
of America, the Lowell
Institute, and Gourmet
Catering, and our media
sponsors, the Boston
Globe, Xfinity, WBUR.
Almost 40 years ago,
President Carter
spoke here at the
dedication of this library.
In his remarks, he
noted that the library
would serve as a place
for the work of reflection
and evaluation of what
President Kennedy did.
This evening, we are so
pleased to have the opportunity
to spend this time reflecting
on the work of President
Carter with our
esteemed special guests.
Stuart Eizenstat was President
Carter's Chief White House
Domestic Policy Advisor.
He served President Clinton
as Ambassador to the European
Union, Undersecretary
of Commerce,
Undersecretary of State, Deputy
Secretary of the Treasury,
and Special Representative
of the President
on Holocaust-era issues.
In the Obama administration,
he was Special Representative
of the Secretary of State
on Holocaust issues.
He is now an international
lawyer with Covington
and Burling in Washington.
He also has a terrific book out.
It really is wonderful.
Meredith Evans was appointed
Director of the Jimmy Carter
Presidential Library and Museum,
administered by the National
Archives and Records
Administration,
in November 2015.
As director, she focuses
on civic engagement,
the role of the presidency
and public policy,
and making accessible
the records of President
Carter, his cabinet, and the
White House administration.
She has written on the role and
value of museums, libraries,
and archives, and has presented
at various international and
national conferences.
Please join me in welcoming our
special guests this evening.
[APPLAUSE]
MEREDITH EVANS: Go
STUART EIZENSTAT: Thank
you very much, Alan.
You know, it's typical
for people to say,
when you see any audience,
that it's a special evening.
But this really is
a special evening
for a variety of reasons.
The first is my
connection to Boston.
I married my late wife
of 45 years, Fran,
who was a Boston native.
We met at Harvard Law School.
And I have the pleasure
of having a number
of my classmates and others--
Ambassador Barry White
and some of my colleagues
have come before.
It is also special because--
and I hope she's here--
one of the people who was
instrumental in my Holocaust
work during the
Clinton administration,
where I negotiated $8 billion
dollars of recoveries.
And she was really the
heroine for the Swiss bank
negotiations.
She's really the one
that pioneered it--
Greta Beer-- and got me
very much involved in it.
It's also special to have
Dr. Meredith Evans here
because of the Carter
Center connection
that I obviously have.
But most pertinent to tonight
is this library itself.
For one thing, I can say
without qualification
that my inspiration
for public service
came from a 1962 speech,
which President Kennedy gave
at Kenan Football Stadium at
Chapel Hill at the University
at North Carolina.
And he urged all of
us to try to serve
our country and the world,
and make it a better place.
And without question, that
was really the catalyst
for my public career.
Like so many in my generation--
I'm sure I'm
speaking for others--
I remember exactly where
I was, to the minute,
when the assassination
occurred in Chapel Hill
at the Science Department.
And I drove up from
Chapel Hill overnight
to be at the US Capitol when his
body was brought from the White
House to the Capitol.
And as Allan said, on
October 20th, 1979,
President Carter, who was
not a great speechmaker,
gave a great speech
here at the opening.
May I say, not because
I helped write it--
[LAUGHTER]
--but because of the
emotion behind it.
And it was emotional for
a variety of reasons,
both because of his
drawing inspiration
from President Kennedy, but also
because it came about two weeks
before the announcement by Ted
that he was running against us.
So we've always
remembered that, and we'll
talk more about that later.
Jimmy Carter's political
hero was Harry Truman.
And he placed his
famous slogan, "The buck
stops here," on his Oval
Office desk on a plaque.
Both presidents left the
White House highly unpopular.
Truman is now remembered much
more for his achievements
than for his failures.
And I'm hopeful that my
book has a similar impact
on a reassessment of
Jimmy Carter as President.
Not just as the most admired,
and as we were talking about,
the longest-serving
former president.
Almost 70% of all
our major legislation
was passed by Congress,
just under the percent
of the first president I served
in the White House, Lyndon
Johnson, after
Harvard Law School.
He honored the presidency.
He respected the institutions
of government, the press--
even when it was brutally
difficult on him because he
realized that it had an
important role in a free
society--
the FBI, the Justice Department.
Walter Mondale,
his Vice President,
put it very succinctly in words
that are on the Carter Center
Foundation.
"We honored the law, we kept the
peace, and we told the truth."
Now, the rap on the
Carter presidency
is summarized in my
book by what I call--
and excuse my Southern
accent-- four Is.
Inflation, Iran, inexperience by
the president and his so-called
Georgia Mafia, of
whom I was one--
I was the experienced guy having
worked a year in the Johnson
White House--
and interparty warfare with
the liberal wing of the party
led by Ted Kennedy.
We'll talk about that
more in a moment.
The problem is these are
very real liabilities.
I am totally candid about them.
It's the reason why The New
York Times and Washington
Post, and many
other publications,
have given us a
very good review.
Because it's not just
an insider's view,
it's an honest view of
his mistakes and failures,
including my own as advisor.
This is not a book that
could have been entitled,
If He Had Only Listened to Me.
[LAUGHTER]
But, also, his achievements,
which have been so
obscured by these problems.
Achievements at home and abroad,
which are of lasting importance
to us this day.
And I wanted to write the
book while there were still
living eyewitnesses, and
before history's verdict
that Jimmy Carter was
a failed president
was so indelibly emblazoned
in people's minds
that that would be
the long and short
of the 39th President
of the United States.
One of the unique
features about the book
is based on a habit I had from
University of North Carolina.
I took it into Harvard
Law School and then
into the White House.
And that was being an
inveterate note taker.
And this book is based
on over 5,000 pages
of contemporaneous verbatim
notes of everything I heard,
everything I saw,
everything I observed,
every meeting that I was in.
They're in the National
Archives and the Carter Library,
and the Library of Congress.
And I augmented that
with 350 interviews,
five of the president himself.
But I was not selective.
I interviewed Republicans
and Democrats, conservatives
and liberals, detractors
and supporters,
so that I could give a
complete and candid assessment
of the Carter presidency.
To understand the
Carter presidency,
you have to understand the
1970s, in which we governed.
It was a decade of
profound and, indeed,
epic change in several ways.
It was the decade in which
we suffered our first loss
in a foreign war in Vietnam, in
which there was urban violence
throughout our major cities.
I remember being on the portico
of the Johnson White House
seeing 16th Street burn.
And it was a decade of a
new economic phenomenon
that even Harvard economists
couldn't give a name to.
So they called it the
ugly name of stagflation,
something we had never had
before and never since--
simultaneous slow growth
and high inflation.
Sort of contradiction
of the Phillips curve.
It was a decade in which a whole
set of new social movements,
which we take for granted
today, burst onto the scene.
The environmental movement,
the consumer movement,
the black power movement
that morphed now
into Black Lives Matter,
the women's rights movement,
now #MeToo.
And after the Roe V. Wade
Supreme Court decision in 1973
on abortion, the
right-to-life movement.
It was a decade in which a
new political force, which
is very much with us in 2019,
was brought onto the scene
by Reverend Jerry Falwell,
a conservative Baptist
minister from
Virginia, who catalyzed
the evangelical movement
into a political force.
He called Carter,
who was probably
the most religious president
we've had in American history,
not a real Baptist, who
was harboring homosexuals
on his staff.
And Ronald Reagan
very adroitly merged
that evangelical movement to
Richard Nixon's silent majority
of dissatisfied blue collar
workers in the Midwest
into a winning
coalition in 1980.
That's precisely the
political coalition
of Donald J. Trump to this day.
Abroad, it was also a
decade of epic change.
We were in the midst
of the Cold War,
and the Soviet Union was
at its most aggressive--
enormous buildups of
military spending in the air,
on the ground, and on the sea.
Encouraging funding and
supporting Cuban proxy troops
for Communist revolutions
in the Horn of Africa,
Angola, Namibia.
Ultimately, as I'll
discuss a little later,
invading Afghanistan--
the first invasion of a country
directly since World War II.
And even supporting
Euro Communist
movements with some
success in Western Europe,
particularly, in Italy.
It was a decade in
which a new major force
came onto the scene.
Tip toeing, at that
time-- now in full force--
the People's Republic of China.
More on that, also, in a minute.
It was a decade in which
a Polish-born priest
became Pope John Paul
II and gave hope,
along with Carter's
human rights campaign,
to those living behind
the Iron Curtain.
And it was a decade in
which a revolution occurred,
which is front page
news to this day
and bedevils us to this day.
And that is the radical
Islamic revolution of Iran.
So let me briefly
take you through
a few domestic achievements
which are totally unrecognized.
The energy security
we enjoy today--
the lack of dependence on
OPEC-imported foreign oil,
which was over 50% when we took
office and growing by leaps
and bounds every month--
owes much to the foundation
that President Carter
laid with three major
energy bills in four years.
Which did everything from ending
price controls on natural gas
and crude oil to encourage
domestic production, which
had been stalled because of the
limited price it could be gone.
This year, 2019, the
United States of America
will be the number one producer
of energy in the world.
More than Saudi Arabia,
more than Russia.
We put conservation at the
center of our energy policy--
the first fuel
economy standards,
the first insulation standards.
And we inaugurated-- and I have
a picture of it in the book--
the solar era of clean
energy, as Carter
put a solar panel on the
White House symbolically.
It was then taken down by
Reagan in the first weeks.
But he couldn't take down the
solar movement, which is now
10% of our total electricity.
Carter was also a great
consumer champion.
Seemed odd, perhaps, for a small
businessman from the South.
He appointed consumer advocates
to regulate industries some
even from Ralph
Nader's organizations.
Not as today,
appointing people who
come from or were lobbyists
for the industries
they're supposed to regulate.
And we married that to
transformative deregulation
of all modes of
transportation to bring
to consumers more competition
and lower prices for buses,
for rail, for trucking,
and most relevant to us
as consumers, airlines.
We would not have the Southwests
and Jet Blues, the efficiency
of the UPS and
FedEx air cargoes,
had we not remove the shackles
which prevented new carriers
from coming in and competing.
We democratized air travel
for the middle class.
That might not seem
too great if you're
sitting in seat 36E
in the economy class,
and you're squeezed and hoping
just to get a drink of water.
But the fact is we opened air
travel to the middle class.
And we didn't stop there.
We went on to begin
the deregulation
of telecommunications and
inaugurated the cable era.
And for those of you who are
aficionados of local craft
beers, we ended even the
Prohibition-era restriction
which prevented their flow.
In addition, Carter
was, without question,
the greatest environmental
president in American history.
Even more than
Theodore Roosevelt.
We doubled the size of Theodore
Roosevelt's National Park
system with the
Alaska Lands Bill,
over the fierce opposition
of the Alaska delegation,
which wanted the whole
state open for oil and gas
exploration.
And in typical Carter detail, he
took a giant map of the state,
laid it on the Oval Office
rug, got on his hands and knees
with Senator Ted Stevens--
the 25-year veteran conservative
Republican senator from
Alaska--
and showed him exactly what
was going to be in the park
and not available for
exploration, what would be.
And Stevens told
us afterward he was
amazed at having represented
the state for 1/4
quarter of a century--
Carter knew more
about it than he did.
We were elected in
'76 against Ford,
in significant part as
a reaction to Watergate.
Carter talked about a government
as good as its people.
"I'll never lie to you."
And that very much resonated.
But this was not just
campaign rhetoric.
Every single piece,
every single piece
of ethics legislation
in force today
in an ethically-challenged
Washington,
came from his vision and was
signed into law with his pen.
The 1978 Ethics Act, for
example, for the first time
required senior officials
going into government
to disclose their assets
and potential conflicts
of interest.
It limited your
ability to take gifts--
then $25 while you're in office.
It limited your ability to
lobby the agencies you were
with after you left office.
Where did Robert
Mueller come from?
It came from the Office
of Special Counsel
we created to
investigate wrongdoing.
We can talk more about the
differences between the two
offices, but it was
clearly the precursor.
We put inspectors general
into every single department
to root out fraud,
waste, and abuse,
reform the civil service system,
had merit selection of judges
by independent
ABA-appointed people.
Now, I got caught up,
unwittingly, in the gift rule.
And that is because
a business magazine
did a profile of me saying--
not totally accurately--
that I had a great love
for the little $0.01 Tootsie
Rolls that many of you
may remember we grew up with.
And so the Tootsie
Roll company sent me
a mammoth box of Tootsie Rolls.
And I was not only
salivating myself,
but I knew I was going to
be the hero to my young kids
when I came home, only to find
out from the ethics officer--
he said, damned if
I'm going to count
every one of these
Tootsie Rolls,
but this box is so large,
it may be worth $25.
You've got to return it.
So I did with a letter to the
CEO, thanking him and saying,
you know, we're now living
on a higher ethical plane.
Sounds great.
Except, a year or
so later, there's
a profile done of the
Tootsie Roll company.
And the CEO says, Eizenstat
tried to have it both ways.
He sends us this high and
mighty letter, we open the box,
it's empty.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm still trying to find
the Secret Service agent who
stole my Tootsie Rolls.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, more seriously, the
first target, remarkably,
of the new Special Counsel
we created by legislation
was none other than
President Carter's own Chief
of Staff, Hamilton Jordan, who
was falsely accused by someone
whose name may ring a bell.
Roy Cohn, who was
the hatchet man
for Senator McCarthy and
the early political advisor
to Donald J. Trump.
And he was representing
the owners of a bar
in New York called Studio 54.
Hamilton should never
have been in that bar,
but they were being
investigated for tax evasion.
And as part of a
plea bargain, he
tried to get them to say that
Hamilton was snorting cocaine,
which he was not, in the bar.
And a year later--
and $1 million
out of Ham's pocket the
grand jury, 24 to 0,
said, totally untrue.
But that's not the point.
The point is that this happened
for a year in our re-election
year-- in 1980--
when Hamilton, who
had been the genius
behind our '76 campaign,
was supposed to do the
same thing in 1980.
It's a total distraction.
Not once-- not once
did Carter call it
a witch hunt,
politically motivated.
We believed in the rule of
law, and we let it play out.
I'll let you draw
your own comparisons.
Here's is a Southern president
from the deepest part
of the Deep South, who appoints
more women, more minorities,
more Jews to judgeships and
to senior administration
officials than all 38 presidents
before him put together.
Some of you may have
seen the documentary RBG.
Or if not, she's
mentioned in my book.
And she said, "I
would never have
been on the Supreme Court
had Jimmy Carter not opened
judgeships to women
and appointed me
to the Court of Appeals for
the District of Columbia."
We supported affirmative
action in admissions.
Harvard is now facing that
issue, of course, now.
We saved New York City and
Chrysler from bankruptcy
and created the
Department of Education--
he was a great education
president-- and much,
much more.
With Walter Mondale
as Vice President,
we took an office that was a
constitutional afterthought.
Any of you who
have seen Hamilton
know what I'm talking about.
And we made it a real position.
John Nance Garner, who was
FDR's first vice president,
said, it's not worth
a bucket of warm spit.
And I'm cleaning the language
up for this audience.
[LAUGHTER]
After we won the '76
election, in the transition,
Mondale sent Carter
10 requests to try
to make something
of this office.
Access to all
classified documents--
did you know that
Harry Truman didn't
know that there
was an atomic bomb
project until after FDR died?
The ability to go into any
meeting without notice,
and one on one meetings with
the president every week,
just the two of them
in the Oval Office,
Carter not only
checked every one.
He did every one.
And then added one that
Mondale didn't even
have the temerity to ask for.
He moved the entire office
of the vice president
into the West Wing just down the
hallway from the Oval Office.
And just like in real estate,
where location is everything,
it is in politics, as well.
It was a symbol that's true to
this day, with Pence and Trump,
that the vice president really
is now an engaged official.
Now, our Achilles
heel, domestically,
was one of those
four I's, inflation.
I'm very candid about it.
We inherited high inflation
from Nixon and Ford.
And it got worse.
It got worse.
And Carter called us
in the summer of 1979,
as we're starting to look
at a re-election year.
And he said, look, I've
got a choice to make.
I have tried everything to deal
with this embedded inflation.
I've had to
anti-inflation czars.
I've given five
anti-inflation speeches.
I've had voluntary wage
and price guidelines
I've had to cut
Social spending to try
to satisfy financial markets.
And it's made me
highly unpopular
with the liberal wing.
Nothing has worked.
And so he said, I'm going to
take the toughest medicine that
the economy can take, even
if it means-- which it did--
his re-election.
He said, I'm going to appoint
Paul Volcker to be chairman
of the Fed, knowing
in advance, as I
describe in a meeting in my
book, just the two of them,
exactly what Volcker
was going to do.
I mean, the contrast, it
was sort of Mutt and Jeff.
And Carter is about 5'9".
And Volcker is 6'7", and a
giant of an intellect, as well,
he'd been president of the
Federal Reserve in New York.
And he said to
Carter exactly this.
If you appoint me, I'm going
to tighten the money supply.
It's going to cause
inflation to go up.
unemployment to go up
in the middle of your election.
If you're not prepared to
support me, don't appoint me.
I don't want the job.
I don't want you saying to me--
just think of what
poor Jerome Powell
goes through when he
raises interest rates
a half of a percent--
don't appoint me if you're
going to point the finger at me
and say, it's Volcker
that's responsible
for the high interest rates.
And Carter said, you
take care of the interest
rates in the economy.
I'll take care of the politics.
A number of us
were very concerned
about the appointment.
And what Volcker did is why
we have low inflation today,
without question.
You can ask Bernanke.
You can ask .
Greenspan you can
ask any economist.
Inflation dropped like a rock
as a result of squeezing it out
of the economy
through high interest
rates and high unemployment.
It dropped like a rock at the
end of Reagan's first year,
not in time for our re-election.
And it's emblematic that
Carter put so many seeds down
which blossomed only
after he left office.
So let's look at some
of the accomplishments
abroad which, in some respects,
are even more significant.
The Camp David Accords and
the Egypt-Israel Peace Treaty
are, in my opinion,
the greatest act
of presidential personal
diplomacy in American history,
more than Woodrow Wilson at
the Paris Peace Conference
after World War I. 13 agonizing
days and nights, Carter
personally drafts 22
separate peace agreements.
And he has to
negotiate separately
with Prime Minister Begin of
Israel and Sadat of Egypt.
Because they were like
two scorpions in a bottle.
We put them together
the first day
and it was a terrible scene.
And then he added
several personal touches,
studying these men-- we
got the CIA profiles.
And he studied them
to understand what
made these two people tick.
Where were their red lines?
And so he adds to
personal touches.
The first Sunday of the
13 days, he takes them
in his presidential
limousine, Begin on his left,
Sadat on his right, to the
Gettysburg battlefield.
And he did that
because he wanted
to drive home that five wars
between Egypt and Israel
were enough.
Now, Sadat was a general.
He had actually studied in some
of our military institutions
here.
He knew all the
problems that the South
had at Gettysburg,
Pickett's last charge,
and so forth, and started
expounding on them,
making it a little
bit uncomfortable
for Carter as a
southern president.
But OK.
Begin was anything
but a general.
But he was a Lincoln scholar.
And on the spot, verbatim, he
delivered Lincoln's Gettysburg
Address.
It's really a very,
very special event.
But even with that, even with
22 drafts, we were close,
the last Sunday,
the 13th day, when
everybody agreed if we can't
get it done we've got to call it
quits.
And Begin comes to Carter
and says, Mr. President,
I cannot and will not
make any more compromises.
I've got an El Al plane waiting
for me at Andrews Air Force
Base.
Get me a White House
car to take me there.
I'm out of here.
Carter realizing that would
collapse Sadat's historic trip
to Jerusalem at
great risk to himself
when he pledged no more wars.
It would inflame the Middle
East and encourage the radicals
like Hafez al-Assad,
Bashar's father.
And it would engulf his own
presidency, a total failure.
He calls them in--
by the way, over the
objection of almost all of us.
Because we said
it was too risky.
And so he does one other
personal touch, knowing
that Begin had a great love
for his eight grandchildren,
a picture had been taken,
photo of the three of them.
The first day at
Camp David, he gets
eight copies, and the names of
each of Begin's grandchildren,
enscribes them to each
with, "hopes for peace.
Best wishes, Jimmy
Carter," hand-delivers
them to Begin at his
cabin at Camp David,
and sees Begin go
through each of them,
vocalize the names of
each of the grandchildren.
He sees pagans lips
quiver and his eyes tear.
Begin puts his
bags down and says,
Mr. President, I'll
make one last try.
And that made Camp
David possible.
But that wasn't the end of it.
Barry and other lawyers here,
Camp David was an accord.
It was a framework.
It wasn't legally binding.
It called for the treaty--
and by the way, full autonomy
for the Palestinians.
That's another story-- the
treaty between Egypt and Israel
within three months of
the close of Camp David.
Six months passed, no treaty.
So Carter, over literally--
I'm not exaggerating--
everybody's objection decides
to go to the region and do
shuttle diplomacy between Cairo
and Jerusalem to see if he
can put the pieces together.
Four days of non-stop
negotiations.
And just like the last
day at Camp David,
we're close, but not there.
And literally everybody gave up.
Air Force One is refueled.
The airspace over Ben
Gurion airport is cleared.
The top aides are already
going from Jerusalem
down to Tel Aviv.
And Begin calls up and
says, Mr. President,
I'd like to see you
once before you leave.
And we thought,
well, it's a courtesy
to say thanks, but no thanks.
And so he gets to the
King David Hotel, where
the president was in the
Presidential Suite, and says,
boys--
because Carter called
us down, and said, look,
we're not ready.
Rosa and I have to get dressed--
to entertain the prime minister.
And so we're bantering.
And he says, now, boys, you
know, this is a famous hotel,
the King David.
Oh, yes, sir, we know that.
But not for the
reasons you think.
When I was head of the Irgun
during the British mandate,
I blew this hotel up.
Don't worry, I'm not going to do
it until the president leaves.
And he goes up to the
Presidential Suite.
That's where the
treaty was finalized.
They come down, the elevator
of this famous hotel.
And the elevator
breaks between floors.
The Secret Service had to pull
the two of them, but-first,
down.
And I call it the breech
birth of the treaty.
MEREDITH EVANS: You're
taking all of my questions.
I'm not going to
have anything left.
STUART EIZENSTAT:
Carter put human rights
at the center of
his foreign policy,
not because it was a sort
of Dewey dot concept,
because he wanted to compete
with the Soviet Union,
and believed that
the way to do it
was to put the best of
America's domestic values
into our foreign policy.
He applied it to the
military dictators
in Latin America, who were
anti-communist, by the way,
and pro-American,
but very repressive.
He got thousands of
prisoners released catalyzed,
the new democratic
movements there,
which flowered in
the '80s, and then
created a new era in
Latin American relations
by marrying it to the
Panama Canal, which
was our toughest battle.
Here's something you would
never see in today's Washington.
One of the heroes of
the Panama Canal Treaty
was the Republican minority
leader, Howard Baker,
a man of very small
physical stature,
but a great man of the Senate.
And he did what he
thought was right,
even though he knew
it would foreclose his
getting the
Republican nomination,
and brings about a
dozen Republicans along.
And the most humorous of those
who put us over the top--
we needed a 2/3
number in the Senate--
was Senator Hayakawa, a
conservative Republican
of California, who coined
the phrase, it's our canal,
we stole it fair and square.
Hardly a likely vote.
So Mondale had worked with
Hayakawa in the Senate,
and knew he had, even my
senate terms, a very high ego.
He puts him on the
phone with Carter.
And Carter says, what
can I do to convince
you to vote for this treaty?
And he said, don't talk
to me about the treaty.
You know what I think about it.
But if you'll let me
come every two weeks
and share my wisdom with
you, then I'll consider it.
And Carter says, Senator,
only every two weeks?
I wouldn't want to
limit you to that.
Flattered, he voted
for the treaty.
And Carter never saw him again.
We also embraced human
rights for the Soviet Union,
applied it to their
soft underbelly,
championed the rights
of Soviet Jewry,
doubled the number of
Soviet Jews who emigrated.
And according Natan
Sharansky, the leader
of the Soviet Jewish
Movement, later,
the head of the Jewish Agency
and a cabinet minister, Carter
saved his life, he
said, by saying,
in the midst of his trial that
he, in fact, was not a US spy.
And we applied hard power.
This is, maybe, one of the
biggest surprises in the book.
Carter is somehow viewed
as weak on defense.
I assert in the book, backed
up by a very new Pentagon study
that's just come out, that all
of the weapons systems that
Reagan deployed-- and I
give him full credit for it,
the MX missile, and
the cruise missile,
and the stealth
bomber, and so forth,
intermediate nuclear
weapons of Europe--
Carter green lighted.
We reversed the post-Vietnam
decline in spending.
And his finest hour, even
his conservative critics say,
his finest hour
was on Afghanistan.
There's never an off
minute in the White House.
Christmas, 1979, the
Soviets invade Afghanistan,
put their own puppet
on the throne.
And Carter reacts with the
Carter Doctrine saying,
military force, if
you go any further,
we put a grain embargo to stop
any grain going to the Soviet
Union four weeks before
the Iowa caucuses,
where they happened to
grow a lot of grain.
We put draft registration in for
young people, hardly popular.
We armed the Mujahideen,
the opposition.
And then, in one of the
most emotional things,
Moscow Olympics
were due in 1980,
this was very important
to their prestige,
and we announced we
were boycotting it.
Just imagine, we get all the
Olympians into the White House.
These kids have trained
for four years to go.
And we have to tell
them they can't.
It was very tough.
So just one or two last things.
China, Nixon and Kissinger
deserve all the credit.
We normalized relations
with China not Nixon Ford,
because of the Taiwan lobby.
We were successful.
Deng Xiaoping comes
to the White House--
I was in the cabinet room--
all 4'11" of him.
He says to the president, thank
you for normalizing relations.
What I really want is I want
the lowest tariff levels
you can give on your products.
And he said, I know there
is a law, Jackson-Vanik,
which precludes it for
countries that bar immigration.
But that's aimed at
the Soviet Union.
We don't.
You write on this
piece of paper--
and he takes a little White
House notepad and pencil--
write on here the number of
Chinese you'd like us to take.
Give you each year, a million?
10 million?
And Carter twinkles and
says, I'll tell you what.
I'll take 10 million
Chinese a year
if you'll take 10,000
American journalists.
Neither had to.
So I'm going to conclude
by talking about Iran.
And then, hopefully, we'll get
into Ted Kennedy and Carter's
problems as a politician.
But I want to conclude
with Iran because it
was the coup de grace that
did end the administration.
I don't think it's
fair to blame Carter
for the Iranian revolution,
for the Shaw's leaving,
any more than its fair
to blame Eisenhower
for the Cuban revolution 90
miles from our shore or Obama
for Mubarak being overthrown.
But having said that, it's
the worst intelligence failure
in American history,
in my opinion.
The CIA had brought a Shah back
on the throne as a 21-year-old.
Every president had given
him an open shopping list.
And yet, they didn't realize
that his domestic support
rested on quicksand and
that, for five years,
he was getting secret
treatments for cancer.
The hostage crisis occurs.
And here, I'll double
back to John Kennedy.
I recommended-- and
this is one time I
wish he had followed my advice.
I advised a blockade
of Iran's harbors
to prevent the oil, which was
their lifeline, from going out.
And I cited John Kennedy's
blockade of Cuba.
Instead, the president has
the hostage families over,
pledges that he's going
to get their loved
ones out safe and
sound, which he does,
but only after 444
humiliating days.
He holds himself up
in the White House--
another mistake-- to show that
he's working full time on this,
doesn't campaign
against Kennedy.
And he made himself the
hostage in the White House.
He caused more press
attention to it.
Walter Cronkite ends every
news program, day 103, day 205,
day 307 of the hostage crisis.
It was like a drop
of poison every day.
And then the straw that broke
the camel's back, the failed
rescue mission at Desert One.
People, again, say
it's Carter's weakness.
He should have had
more helicopters.
Not true.
The military wanted six.
Carter added two
more for insurance.
That was the maximum they could
fit under an aircraft carrier
and avoid Soviet reconnaissance.
It failed.
Because everything
that could go wrong did
go wrong, including dust storms.
But most fundamentally,
because, believe it or not,
there was no joint military
command for the four
military services
that had to cooperate,
and when the rotor blade
of one of the helicopters
hit the C130 cargo
plane full of fuel
to get the helicopters into
Tehran, it burst into flames.
Eight servicemen died.
And it engulfed our
administration, as well.
So again, we'll conclude.
I'll get some questions where
I can talk more about Carter
as a politician and Ted Kennedy.
I'm not nominating Jimmy
Carter for Mount Rushmore
in this book.
I am suggesting he
belongs in the foothills
with other presidents who
have made their country
and the world a better place.
Thank you.
And again, I'll
look forward to--
[APPLAUSE]
MEREDITH EVANS: I
started out taking notes.
And then I realized I was
checking off the questions
I was going to ask.
Because he answered them.
Amazing, right?
You would think I would
learn, having spent time
with President Carter myself,
that they're well read
and take copious
notes, as you can see.
So just a few things.
You talked a lot already.
Could you speak more to
President Carter's foresight?
We have one of the solar panels
that he put on the White House
in our library.
And people are always
shocked to see it.
So early to think
about solar panels.
You talked about the diversity
in women and people of color
that he appointed.
What other things
can you think of?
There's health care.
I don't think many
people know that there
was a universal
health care policy
that President
Carter and his team
were trying to
implement, as well.
So could you just speak
to some of the things
that he's done that were
really before your time
during those years?
STUART EIZENSTAT: Sure.
So I'll mention that.
Then I'd like to get in
to Carter as a politician
and as a person.
Because I think it's very
important to understand that.
I do want to recognize, by
the way, a cousin, Harriet
and Jeff Brandt, who are here.
International Refugee Week
is going to be coming.
And just contrast that
with what we have today.
1975, you remember the famous
picture of the US helicopter
leaving the US embassy in
Saigon, people hanging on?
So the North Vietnamese
take over the whole country.
And anybody connected with the
south, directly or indirectly,
is, to say the least, at risk.
There's an enormous
outflow in the South China
Sea of boat people, the
original boat people
and they're sinking
in their craft.
Mondale, in what
was his finest hour,
calls an international
convention,
reminds people of the
Evian Conference in '38
under Roosevelt, where Jews
were-- their death sentence
came then when no country would
lift its immigration quotas.
And he says that specifically.
And we ended up taking 500,000
Vietnamese into this country.
Carter orders the
Navy, which didn't want
to do it, to pick the
people up from the boats.
So at a time when
immigration and refugees are
so controversial, this
is something to remember.
Now, this gets me to--
and again I want to talk
about Carter as a politician,
and then, hopefully, get into
the Ted Kennedy issue, which
we have to do at this library.
So Carter's great strength
was also his great weakness.
He was a ferocious campaigner.
But he believed that, once
you were in the Oval Office,
you park politics at
the Oval Office door.
And you did, quote,
unquote, "the right thing."
And that's why he was able
to do so many of the things
I mentioned that were
politically unpopular.
Panama was terrible.
I mean, Rosalynn begged
him not to do it,
and the Middle East, and energy.
These were all political losers.
But it was also a weakness.
Because a president is not
just commander in chief.
He has to be
politician in chief.
He has to nurture his base.
He has to keep his party
behind him, something
that Trump does very well.
And Carter lost his party.
He ended up being too
conservative for the liberals
and too liberal for
the conservatives.
And so, when Ted Kennedy
ran against him--
it's, again, one of those
I's, inter-party warfare.
And permit me just to
talk a minute about this.
Because it's a very
important piece of the book.
And one can hardly
not talk about it
when Ted's papers
are here, when he's
got an institute a
stone's throw from here.
But if you want to go into
something else first--
MEREDITH EVANS: No.
I'd like you-- let's lead into--
talk about the
health care policies
that President Carter was--
STUART EIZENSTAT: Well,
the health care policy
is at the center of Ted's run.
I want to say, by the way,
that I am the only Carter
aide Ted asked to be
interviewed for his archives.
So here's the story.
Ted Kennedy had one
of the highest support
rankings of any senator
for our legislation.
We wouldn't have gotten
airline deregulation
passed without him.
After the election,
we win six states
and the District of Columbia.
Ted calls up and
says, Stu, there's
a vacancy on the First Circuit
Court of Appeals in Boston.
You know what Stephen
Breyer has done
working with you
and the president
on airline deregulation,
a professor at Harvard.
And I said, Ted,
the only problem
is, there are two
insurmountable hurdles.
What are those?
The first is, Carter
has no love lost
because you ran against him.
And he said, I know.
That's why I'm calling
you and not the president.
He said, what's the other one?
Think of Merrick Garland.
I said, Ted, we lost the Senate.
Strom Thurmond's going to be
the chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee.
Why wouldn't he wait
two and a half months
'til Reagan's in office
and appoint a conservative?
You take care of Carter.
I'll take care of Strom.
I go into Carter with one
of my legal [INAUDIBLE]..
I got 10 reasons why he
should appoint Steve.
I said, don't ask me who asked.
But you should appoint him.
You remember what he said.
Yeah.
It'll be a tribute.
OK.
Call Ted, I've done my part.
How about yours?
Strom's in my pocket.
I said, how is that?
You guys are
political opposites.
He said, well, Steve has
breakfast every morning
with Emory Sneeden.
They work things out
on a bipartisan basis.
Ted Kennedy was incredible.
We had nominated Steve
to the first circuit.
He wouldn't be on the
Supreme Court without it.
He passed unanimously in a lame
duck session with a lame duck
president.
OK, now, Ted's number
one goal, from the day
he came into the Senate
to the day he died,
was health care, national
health insurance.
He had gone through so many
iterations, Kennedy-Mills,
Kennedy-Corman, et cetera.
We pledged to support health
care in the '76 campaign.
But Carter didn't want that
to be the first thing out
of the box because it was so
difficult, and so complex,
and so costly.
So we negotiated with
Ted for two years.
I personally negotiated with
him for weeks in his Senate
and his Capital office.
And we reached an agreement
on a multi-phased program.
Ted moved off of his
single-payer-- sound familiar--
single payer
program and accepted
our concept of
employer-paid premiums
and expansion of
Medicaid, covering
young kids and the elderly.
Almost exactly
what Obamacare is.
And we agreed that it
would be phased in.
Ted agreed to the entire thing.
And then, at the last second,
labor put pressure on him
to take a single payer.
It collapsed.
20 years later, it took 20
years to get health insurance.
And he said to one of
his aides, and quote her
in the book, "after
another failed attempt,
where's the Carter Bill
when we really need it?"
Now, you have to understand
the intensity of the opposition
that Ted brought
to this challenge.
We beat him two to
one in delegates
going into the convention.
He tried to get the Rules
Committee to support
a so-called open
convention, meaning
that the delegates
who were pledged
to abide by the results of
their primaries and caucuses
would be open to vote
for whoever they wanted.
The chairman of
the Rules Committee
was Senator Danny
Inouye, who had--
representing Hawaii,
Japanese-American,
family interred in
California during the war,
looses an arm in Italy
fighting in a war.
And he says to us, after
the Rules Committee,
this is the most angry,
sweat-laden meeting
I've been in since the war.
There are over 50
minority planks,
including health insurance, on
the floor of the convention.
Instead of reconciling
after the convention,
he gives this speech, stealing
the soul of the convention,
the dream will never die.
He doesn't give the
traditional handshake.
And so we went into
the general election
hobbled with a divided party.
Would we have lost anyway?
Maybe, maybe because of Iran,
maybe because inflation.
But I can tell you that we
were substantially weakened.
It's something I've
never understood.
Ted and I had a great
relationship through it
all and afterward.
But it's something that
history has to explain.
MEREDITH EVANS: So you
talked about President Carter
as a politician and versus
himself, how he normally is,
with his value system.
The two are kind
of one in the same.
He's a very humble person.
He has a strong value system.
And he leads in
what he believes.
If he's able to
unite global leaders,
what was the challenge with
uniting within the party?
STUART EIZENSTAT: That's
a really good question.
I mean, he did so much better
in international affairs,
not just Camp David,
not just China,
but so many other major
achievements abroad that I
mention in the book,
including what's known--
by a Harvard
professor, by the way,
Robert Putnam from
the Kennedy School--
as the single best
economic summit in history,
the Bonn Summit, where we got
all the countries to agree
to stimulate their economies.
We got the trade round
done, and so forth.
So what was the difference?
And the difference
goes to Carter.
And again, it's his uniqueness,
his strength, and his weakness.
He has a very
strong moral streak.
One of the things a
President has to do
is, when he proposes
legislation, and if he's lucky,
he gets half of it back.
Say it's the best thing
since sliced bread.
As Bob Strauss once said,
making lemonade out of a lemon.
Carter never could do that.
He would always focus on
what hadn't been done.
Compromise was very difficult.
He had a strong morality.
He saw something that
needed to be done.
He proposed something.
And when other people
didn't see it that way,
and they wanted a local
dam built, or a highway,
or bridge in return for a vote,
it rankled the hell out of him.
And he had difficulty doing it.
Again, it's a highly
political office.
And you have to be
willing to do it.
Not withstanding that,
because of his vision,
and because of
his determination,
we got 70% passed.
But it always was done in
a difficult and almost ugly
fashion, with it making look
like he was being dragged
to the altar rather
than dragging
the members of Congress there.
MEREDITH EVANS: So talk
about his first 100
days as president.
He basically reorganized
several, if not all,
departments in many ways.
What was the struggle with that?
If you're saying
that his morality is
sort of his weakness, right, and
there's challenges with that,
is that part of the
100 days of his?
STUART EIZENSTAT: So he made
a very critical decision.
On December 9th, 1976,
after the election,
during the transition,
before he's inaugurated,
he misread the
lessons of Watergate.
H.R. Haldeman was
Nixon's chief of staff.
He was awful.
He kept everybody away.
He isolated Nixon.
And Carter said, I'm
not going to have that.
And so he allowed five
or six of his top aides,
myself included, to have
equal access to him,
with no chief of staff.
And it was called, after
Jack Kennedy, that's
the way Kennedy initially
organized his White House,
called the spokes of the
wheel, with the president
at the center, and
five or six spokes.
OK, now, Ford had tried
to do the same thing.
He was a congressman.
He comes into the office
after the resignation.
And he organizes
it the same way.
And I have, in my interview with
Dick Cheney, a disaster, chaos,
nobody setting priorities.
And after a couple of months,
he appoints first Rumsfeld, then
Cheney as chief of
staff, to bring order,
to bring priorities.
And Cheney says that,
after they lost,
the Ford White House staff
does a roast for him.
And they give him, as
a going away present,
a huge plaque with a
broken bicycle wheel saying
"don't do the spokes
of the wheel."
And he leaves it in
Ham Jordan's office,
when Carter comes in,
with a note saying,
don't repeat our mistakes.
We did.
And so the problem
with the first 100 days
is there weren't any priorities.
There was welfare reform, tax
reform, reorganization, Panama,
the SALT nuclear treaty,
energy legislation,
too much for Congress to digest.
No priorities were set.
I mean, Tip O'Neill,
of course, from Boston,
would beg him at the
leadership breakfasts,
tell us what your
priorities are.
We can't handle all of this.
So that's another thing.
We got so much back.
But compared to
what we brought in,
it looked like it
was chicken feed.
It wasn't.
It was huge.
But we just proposed too much.
And again, it was
a serious mistake.
It was two and a
half years before he
appointed a chief of staff.
MEREDITH EVANS: Yeah.
They also say that
he reads everything.
And I can attest to that.
He reads a lot.
And when you're president, and
don't have a chief of staff,
that's not consumable.
STUART EIZENSTAT: No.
You have nobody to--
I mean, look,
Carter, like I did,
took the Evelyn Woods
Reading Dynamics Course.
He was a speed reader.
And he is a speed reader.
He has a voracious
interest in everything.
And it was a fault, for sure,
it was a fault, for sure,
that he would take our
decision memoranda, which
I would help prepare,
and he would always
ask for the appendices
and more information.
He would bring back
some of my memos
with misspellings and
punctuation marks.
And I used to think that it
was terrible for a president
to get too much information.
Now, I think it's a lot better
than getting no information.
MEREDITH EVANS: To this
day, he still does that.
He corrects memos.
I've had one of those typos
circled on me, before.
So let's go back, all the
way to the '76 campaign.
Did you work on that campaign?
Or did you--
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yeah.
So this is a good example--
I did.
It's a good example to young
people, and maybe to all of us,
that sometimes, you
should follow your heart
and not your head.
So I graduated from
Harvard Law School.
I go into the Johnson
White House for a year.
I left because he decided
not to run for re-election.
My office is next to Humphrey's
office and the Executive Office
Building.
I knew the Humphrey staff.
I had joined Humphrey's staff
as his research director
from the first to the
last day against Nixon.
He loses.
I go back to Atlanta,
clerk for a federal judge.
And I make a beeline for
the office of Carl Sanders,
who had been the
governor before ,
had parlayed that into a
very successful law practice.
I come in as an Atlanta
native, and so forth.
And I said, Governor-- he
couldn't succeed himself
immediately under the
Georgia constitution.
But he could run for a
second term after four years.
So he was the odds-on favorite.
And I said, look, I'm
an Atlanta native,
a high school All-American,
Grady High School,
and Harvard Law School,
and the White House,
and Humphrey, and all that.
And I'd like to volunteer
for your campaign staff
when you formally announce.
And he sort of gave a nod.
Now, what did you need me for?
He was the odds-on favorite.
He had all the money,
sumptuous law office,
double breasted suit.
And then my high school
classmate, Henry Bower,
says, you ought to go see
this state senator who's
running for governor.
He's lost one since in '66.
He's running again.
I said, no.
I can't do it.
I mean, I've already
committed to Carl Sanders.
And he bugs me so much that I
go to see Carter in a office
building right opposite the
federal courthouse in Atlanta.
And it's the exact opposite
of this sumptuous law office.
I'm not exaggerating, there
is a aluminum folding table
with two folding chairs.
And Carter, not in a
tie and sumptuous suit,
but in work boots with khaki
slacks and a work shirt.
And he starts talking to me.
And I am entranced, not
just because he's handsome,
but because here's someone from
the deepest part of the Deep
South.
You have to go to
Plains, Georgia,
this gnat-infested place of
500 people, to understand.
No traffic lights, then or now.
But he understands urban issues.
He's going to come out, as
gubernatorial candidate,
in favor of mass
transit for Atlanta,
in favor of reorganizing
the state government,
in favor of education, and,
this was the key thing for me,
in favor of civil rights.
At his inauguration, he says,
the time for discrimination
is over.
Still, I felt, OK, I got
a commitment to Sanders.
He calls me back a second
time, and then, again, I
followed my heart
and not my head.
Because my head would have
said, go with the favorite.
I became his policy director
as a gubernatorial candidate,
his policy director as
president, his domestic advisor
after that.
So, again, sometimes
you should follow
your instincts and your
heart and not your head.
MEREDITH EVANS: What things were
different about that governor
campaign versus
running for president?
Did he change in any way?
STUART EIZENSTAT:
He had to change.
Because, when he
ran for governor,
he went to every one
of the 159 counties.
Georgia is the second-largest
state, geographically, east
of the Mississippi.
Every single state,
tireless campaigner.
Now, that also was true
when he ran for president,
but with some
important exceptions.
Ham Jordan wrote a 74-page,
single-spaced memorandum
of how to take this
unknown Georgia governor
and make him president.
He goes on What's My Line, OK?
Remember the program,
What's My Line?
And nobody guesses that he's
the governor of Georgia.
So, I mean, he starts with
zero name recognition.
He spends 100 days campaigning
before the Iowa caucuses,
understanding as Ham did,
and the other candidates
who were better known didn't,
that if you win that caucus,
it's a catapult
for New Hampshire.
And you know how he won the
caucus, beside 100 votes,
100 times there?
Because every president
who's successful,
every president
understands the mood of
the public at that moment.
It may be different four years
before and four years hence.
And he understood that even
democratic voters didn't
want a renewed Great Society.
They wanted to remove
the stain of Watergate.
They wanted an outsider
of high morals and ethics.
OK.
Then we win with 27%
of the vote in Iowa.
Bayh, who just
died, unfortunately,
a great man, 13%, Mo
Udall, 10%, undecided, 60%.
Headline, "Carter Wins Iowa."
And then it was on to New
Hampshire, and so forth.
But when you're
running for president,
you cannot go everywhere.
You've got to start
speaking more broadly.
You've got to pick your places.
You've got to pick your issues.
And you've got to
pick your message.
If the message is too
diffuse, you lose.
We had three debates with Ford.
And those were decisive,
particularly the second debate,
on foreign policy, where
Carter, the supposed novice
against the 25-year
veteran, Gerald Ford.
And Ford has asked
the basic question
by Max Frankel from
The New York Times,
Mr. President, some
of your top aides
seem to talk about the Soviet
influence in Eastern Europe.
Says Ford, the Soviets
don't occupy Eastern Europe.
They don't control
Eastern Europe.
That was decisive.
Carter turns and says, tell
that to the Czech-Americans,
and the Hungarian-Americans,
and the people whose families
are behind the Iron Curtain?
It took away all of
Ford's advantage.
And it was very decisive.
Now, one last thing, we come
out of the Democratic Convention
with a 30-point lead over Ford.
30 point lead!
OK, it was inflated
a little bit,
in the sense that, after
conventions, you get a boost.
But 30%!
We lost all but a half of 1%.
Why?
And this is decisive for him
going into the White House.
He campaigned as an
outsider, as a new Democrat,
as a different Democrat.
And when he gets the
nomination in New York,
and all the barnacles
of the party, the labor
movement, and all the
others, latch onto him,
and he starts to
take on those-- he
becomes like a
traditional Democrat.
He called it, in one of
the interviews that I had,
an albatross around his neck.
And so he was never
quite comfortable
in the skin of a traditional
Democrat, as Ted was,
of course.
MEREDITH EVANS: Yeah.
I can see that.
I think part of that campaign,
it was a family affair.
His son's campaigned.
Mrs. Carter campaigned.
STUART EIZENSTAT: Well,
you had the peanut brigade.
You had Dot Padgett with
the peanut brigade going
into New Hampshire,
with hundreds
of people, and
his family, going.
MEREDITH EVANS: There's
some serious differences
between then and now.
I think about President
Carter's relationship
with Ford was very amicable.
How much do you
think it cost for him
to campaign for president?
STUART EIZENSTAT: So
Carter spent, and Ford,
under the checkoff system
then in place, $20 million.
$20 million for a
presidential campaign.
I mean, you can't
run the first week
of a congressional campaign
for $20 million dollars.
It's changed so much with
the money in politics.
I do want to give you one
anecdote from the campaign.
Because my book really has
wonderful profiles of people
who could, kind of, out
of a Shakespearean play,
the sort of heroic, and the
tragic, and the humorous,
and the villainous,
and one, who,
you have to understand to
understand Jimmy Carter,
is his mother, Miss Lillian.
So in her 20s, she is
a registered nurse.
She takes care of black
and white patients,
never done at that
time, gets paid
in chickens and vegetables.
At age 68, goes into the
Peace Corps in India,
and has a luminescent smile.
And she becomes, of course,
during his campaign in '76,
one of his chief supporters.
So a reporter comes
down from New York
to quiz her about
her son's slogan,
"I'll never lie to you."
And this New York reporter
comes to planes and says,
now, come on Miss
Lillian, you must know,
as his mother, that he must have
lied all the time growing up.
Honey, he told white
lies all the time.
Well, what do you mean by
a white lie, Miss Lillian?
Well, you know how I said
it was wonderful to have you
down here from New York to
Plains, that was a white lie.
[LAUGHTER]
MEREDITH EVANS: So I have
a poster in my office
from the campaign.
And it says, "there's a
simple and effective way
for public officials
to regain public trust.
And that's to be trustworthy."
And you talked a lot about
President Carter's morality.
We know that he's very
connected to his family.
And that transcends
into his leadership.
Can you say a little
bit, before we open it up
for questions from the audience,
about the boat-lift in 1980,
a little bit more,
how that speaks
to his humanitarian-ness,
his civil rights?
That's his legacy, even
through the Carter Center,
his desire for people to have
housing, and food, and just
basic needs, and a place to
rebuild their lives, right?
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yes.
And this, also, we can
talk about it, perhaps,
in questions from
the audience, to hear
about the Palestinian
issue, too.
So here's, again, someone coming
from the most conservative part
of the Deep South.
His playmates, but
not his classmates,
were African-Americans.
Sumter County is 2/3 black.
So he would play
stickball with them.
And then they would go
their separate ways.
And he told me, in
one of the interviews,
that one of the
formative things for him
is that he goes into the
Navy, into the nuclear Navy.
The only major argument
he and Rosalynn had,
I think, in 72 years, after
his father contracts cancer,
he decides to leave a
very promising career
as a nuclear submarine
officer and come back
to this little hamlet.
That's the last thing
that Rosalynn wanted.
And his first elected office
is to Sumter County Board
of Education.
And he tells me this anecdote.
He starts to-- this is during
the separate but equal period,
right?
Separate but equal schools.
So he starts touring the black
schools in Sumter County.
And he says, I find,
first, the black students
have either no books or just
broken and discarded books.
And second, the desks that
teenage high school students
are supposed to sit at
are four five-year-olds.
It was really something
emblazoned in his mind.
It's, again, why
he said, when he
was in his inaugural
speech as governor,
the time for
discrimination is over.
It's why he became a great civil
rights champion as president,
supporting affirmative action,
against his southern base,
I mean, against
his southern base.
So this, I mean, this, to me,
was one of the most important--
and then, you mentioned,
again, the boatlift
and the Human Rights Campaign.
It was all part of this.
Human rights, to him, were
a foreign policy equivalent
of civil rights at home.
Just that direct equation.
Now, look, there were
times you couldn't
apply human rights abroad.
We gave the Shah,
largely, a pass.
We did.
I mean, you can't apply it
everywhere in every occasion.
But it was a centerpiece
of his foreign policy.
And again, for him,
it was the opposite.
And we could talk
about this longer.
This is where his view
on the Palestinians come.
MEREDITH EVANS: Yeah.
Are there mics?
So I'm sure there's some
questions, although he answered
probably most of them already.
He's very good at that.
There are some mics, I
think, in the aisles.
It's hard to see.
Yep, mics in the aisles.
So if anybody has a question,
this is a good time.
STUART EIZENSTAT: If
there are no questions,
I'm leaving right now.
I mean, there've
got to be questions.
OK.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
MEREDITH EVANS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is this--
MEREDITH EVANS: It's on.
AUDIENCE: So I
just had a question
about another humanitarian,
Eleanor Roosevelt,
who, in 1977, if I'm
correct, he made Val-Kill
into a national park, the
only national park dedicated
to a first lady.
I wanted to find out what
the background was for that,
and how it all transpired?
Thank you.
STUART EIZENSTAT: Thank you.
So the relationship
with Eleanor Roosevelt
really came through Rosalynn.
Because Rosalynn emulated her
role as First Lady from hers.
And here, again, I have a
long profile of Rosalynn.
She was so shy when he was
first running for governor,
she literally could
not speak on a podium.
And she comes into
the White House.
And she blossoms like
a beautiful flower.
She becomes only the
second first lady
next to Eleanor Roosevelt
to testify in Congress
on her own bill,
which she drafted,
the Humane Mental Health Bill.
She attends cabinet meetings.
She becomes a political partner.
The president, like
Eleanor, was for FDR.
So it was really
her relationship
with Eleanor's memory.
And one of the reasons why
Carter was such a feminist--
and I use that term advisedly--
in terms of appointing women
and so forth to
non-traditional positions,
like assistant secretary
of defense, OK,
was, in part,
because of Rosalynn.
And this is what-- it
just bothers me so much.
Look, I've told you very
frankly his limitations
as a politician.
But he was a great
man in his vision.
And his party abandoned
him as well as he not
get his party together.
So this goes to the women,
and to Eleanor Roosevelt.
He appoints all these women.
He appoints the first
presidential commission
on the status of women, headed
by Bella Abzug, remember her?
And she walks off the
commission because he's not
funding some of the
social programs enough
and campaigns against him.
Labor, we raised
the minimum wage,
we create 10 million jobs.
He comes from a right-to-work,
non-union state,
and he supports labor law reform
to make it easier to organize.
We have jobs programs,
youth employment programs.
Labor backs Kennedy and not us.
Same with the Jewish Community,
Camp David, and the piece,
we break the back
of the Arab boycott.
He's the father of the US
Holocaust Memorial Museum,
the father of the museum,
the presidential commission,
Soviet Jewish emigration.
And the only good thing to
come out of Iran, beside,
finally getting
the hostages out,
we saved 50,000
Iranian Jews, refugees,
by bending the visa laws,
frankly, and getting them out
of Tehran, and allowing those
who were in and would have been
subject to our executive
order expelling
Iranians in the United States
out of the hostage crisis.
And yet, he gets the lowest
percentage of Jewish votes
of any Democratic president or
candidate in modern times, 40%.
For God's sake,
McGovern gets 70%.
That's, again, another story.
But in any event, the point
is that Eleanor Roosevelt was
a great figure for Rosalynn.
MEREDITH EVANS: I'm so
happy you said that.
I think Rosalynn
Carter's probably
one of the best first ladies.
Ever she's the best-kept
secret, in many ways.
So--
STUART EIZENSTAT: She
was, in some respects,
a tougher politician.
I mean, I mentioned Panama.
She said, Jimmy,
don't do Panama.
It's electric.
Every president going back
to LBJ has tried to do it.
And they've dropped it.
Wait 'til your second term.
And he said, suppose I
don't have a second term.
MEREDITH EVANS: She was also
good on the campaign trail.
They would ask her about
her favorite recipes.
And she'd say, I'm
not here for that.
I'm here to talk politics.
Ma'am.
AUDIENCE: I am a Dr.
Carter by marriage.
And I appreciate Jimmy Carter.
Because he's that
champion of human rights.
I belong to his library
and museum in Atlanta.
And I don't know if many
people know all the things
that Jimmy Carter did in favor
of for the people in Africa.
[INAUDIBLE] use his money
to build a hospital,
and other thing.
Now, you were an advisor.
Were you an advisor during
the political campaign?
Or all after President
Carter was elected?
STUART EIZENSTAT: I'm not sure
I understood her question?
MEREDITH EVANS: So
is your question--
AUDIENCE: Is, if
he was an advisor
to the political
campaign in 1976?
MEREDITH EVANS: Were you
an advisor and in '76?
to President Carter?
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yes,
yes, the whole time, sure.
AUDIENCE: Because one
of the winning cards--
STUART EIZENSTAT: But I mean,
if you're talking about Africa--
are you talking about Africa?
AUDIENCE: Well, I was talking
about work he's doing today.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--all over the years,
after the presidency.
But what I'm asking
you is, if you
were his advisor during his
political campaign in 1976?
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yes.
AUDIENCE: One of
the winning cards--
because President
Carter has been, always,
against the abuse of people,
in favor of human rights.
One of the winning
cards the last debate
with Gerald Ford, who is,
today, the only president who
was never elected
by the Americans,
was the question that
Carter asked Ford
about the involvement
of the United States
with the coupe in
Chile, with Pinochet.
Ford didn't know how to--
STUART EIZENSTAT: Ma'am,
you've talked a long time.
So let me--
MEREDITH EVANS: So
is your question--
STUART EIZENSTAT:
What is your question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, the
question is, are you aware
that one of the winning
cards for President Carter
was because Carter point to
Ford to ask questions of Ford
about their
political involvement
with the coup in Chile,
with Pinochet Ford didn't
know how to answer.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MEREDITH EVANS:
She's asking about--
STUART EIZENSTAT:
Yes, I understand.
So we took on all the military
dictators, Argentina, Chile--
AUDIENCE: I know that.
STUART EIZENSTAT: --Bolivia.
And we cut their arms
off, military arms off,
because of their repression.
AUDIENCE: So, my--
STUART EIZENSTAT: I'm
sorry, ma'am, please.
I think, in fairness,
would you let other--
I don't know, really,
what you're asking.
But I can only say, he took on
the military dictators there.
He did in Africa.
I just-- I'm not sure
what else you're asking.
AUDIENCE: What I'm saying
is that the Carter warned
the presidency
against Gerald Ford--
STUART EIZENSTAT: Can
you please stop this?
MEREDITH EVANS: She's
saying that he won--
you're saying that he won
the presidency because
of his global work?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
He was upset about--
he ask a question.
Ford didn't know how
to answer any question.
[INAUDIBLE] He look
very bad about that one.
MEREDITH EVANS: I
thank you for that.
Thank you for bringing
that to our attention.
AUDIENCE: Because
it's the truth.
MEREDITH EVANS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MEREDITH EVANS: Sir?
Oh.
Sir, right here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, me.
MEREDITH EVANS: Yes!
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
There's two things
I'd like to say.
First off, I am the recipient
of socialized health care.
MEREDITH EVANS: OK.
AUDIENCE: You guys pay
for my health care.
I wish I could pay for yours.
And granted, it's the VA.
But they treat me wonderfully.
They've kept me alive for
a long period of time.
Now, the thing
that I want to ask
is, when I see a shadow
of a president standing
with three people trying
to privatize the Veteran's
Administration, how
well do you think
this is going to go over
with the American people?
MEREDITH EVANS: Interesting.
STUART EIZENSTAT: Well, I
mean, privatizing the VA,
it won't go one inch.
I mean, it's a very popular
program for veterans.
And it has no chance of being,
and shouldn't be, privatized.
AUDIENCE: I agree.
I agree with you.
I just am wondering--
STUART EIZENSTAT: I can tell you
that our VA chief, Max Cleland,
was a triple amputee
from Vietnam.
And we were great
supporters of the VA system.
MEREDITH EVANS: I don't want to
say anything bad about Kennedy.
But if he had voted
on Carter's side,
we would have health care, paid
for children up to 12, right?
AUDIENCE: I agree.
STUART EIZENSTAT: We were
going to expand Medicaid
dramatically.
We were providing
employer-paid insurance.
We were expanding the VA.
We were going to cover children
and catastrophic health care.
And as Obama has learned,
ours is an incremental system.
You just can't do
everything at once.
And the VA is important.
But thinking that we can
have Medicare for all,
and abandon the whole
private insurance system,
doesn't work, either.
You have to have a
combination of the two.
MEREDITH EVANS: It would
have been nice, though.
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yes, please.
MEREDITH EVANS: Thank
you for your question.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my question
is about nuclear weapons.
What was President Carter's
concern about nuclear weapons
during his administration?
And how does he feel
about them today?
STUART EIZENSTAT: OK.
So he was a nuclear engineer.
He was an officer
in a nuclear sub.
And years later, when
the SS Jimmy Carter
was christened in
Connecticut, at Groton,
it was the last Nautilus
Class submarine.
I went into it for a tour.
And I came back.
And I said to my
wife, Fran, I said,
it's unbelievable to think
that people stay underground
for 60 to 90 days in
this cramped quarter.
So he understood nuclear
power more than anyone.
He had a great concern
about nuclear proliferation
and negotiated the SALT II
to Nuclear Arms Reduction
Treaty with the Soviet Union.
So here is-- again,
I want to try
to put this in today's terms so
you understand how much we've
lost from the mentality there.
I mentioned, already, Panama,
how we had bipartisan support.
OK.
So we're going into 1980.
Reagan is opposed
to SALT. Still,
we have a heavily
democratic Senate.
And then there's a finding
of a Soviet brigade in Cuba.
Here we go back to
Jack Kennedy again.
This was a secret protocol
in the Cuban Missile Crisis,
it was never made
public, that the Soviets
would be allowed to keep 2,000
defensive troops in Cuba.
This was just their successors.
Everybody makes a
big to-deal of it.
The Soviets are on our doorstep.
SALT doesn't pass.
But here's what happened.
Reagan comes into office.
And for the full term of SALT,
seven years, both the Soviets,
Gorbachev, and Reagan,
abide by that treaty
as if it had been ratified.
Just look at what happens today.
The nuclear agreement
with Iran, we pull out of.
The agreement called the
Trans-Pacific Partnership,
we pull out of.
The INF Treaty, we pull out of.
The Paris Piece
Accords, we pull out of.
I mean, presidents
are supposed to--
there's a continuity,
so foreign governments
can trust the word of United
States, when we reach a treaty,
that our successor is
going to honor the treaty.
Reagan did, to his credit.
MEREDITH EVANS: So we
barely have enough time.
So what I'd like to do is
hear the last two questions.
And then you can give short
answers to both questions.
Can we do it?
I'm going to start--
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yes and no.
MEREDITH EVANS: Can I
start-- let me start here.
Because you've been waiting.
So, sir, can you give
us your question?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I'd just like to ask,
it's a little-known fact
that the negotiation of the
release of the hostages in Iran
was actually negotiated by
the Carter administration.
But it occurred shortly
after Ronald Reagan
had been inaugurated.
What was the final negotiations
during the final days
of the White House?
MEREDITH EVANS: Can I see that?
Yeah, OK.
STUART EIZENSTAT: Yeah, OK.
MEREDITH EVANS: So you want
to know what the final--
AUDIENCE: What was the final
days of the White House like?
MEREDITH EVANS:
What was that like?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
what was it like?
What was the process the Carter
administration went through
to negotiate with Iran
to get the hostages out?
And just a quick
final question, what
was the Carter
administration's reaction
to them being released
so soon after Carter
had been taken out, thus
giving the success to Reagan?
MEREDITH EVANS: Thank you.
Sir, question?
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to mention
that I nominated President
Carter for the Profile
in Courage Award, which is given
by this presidential library,
because of the, I believe,
the very underestimated
presidency that he had.
And I believe that
everyone in this audience
can attest to is his very
successful post-presidency.
STUART EIZENSTAT:
Tell me your name.
AUDIENCE: My name
is Vincent Bonito.
And I am from New Jersey.
STUART EIZENSTAT:
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: And I am a
proud Kennedy Democrat.
I do have a quick question,
if you could expand.
MEREDITH EVANS: You knew I
was going to ask that, right?
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: What, if any,
was the relationship
like between President Carter
and the late President Reagan,
if you please?
MEREDITH EVANS: So which one
would you like to answer first?
STUART EIZENSTAT: OK, so I'll
take the first question first.
Khomeini, who was the leader
of the Iranian revolution,
hated Jimmy Carter
because Carter embodied,
to him, all the presidents
who had supported the Shah.
We had several agreements
to release the hostages
with his government, every
one of which he vetoed.
Now, here is a question.
And Gary Sick, who was our Iran
expert on national Security
Council, wrote a
book about this,
there were congressional
hearings which
were inconclusive, how is it
that the hostages were released
the minute Reagan is sworn in,
and not before the election,
or even when we're
in the transition?
I mean we reached the agreement.
How is it?
So the allegation
was made by Gary
that the Reagan people went
to Khomeini and said to him,
don't release the hostages.
It will win the
election for Carter.
And if you don't,
you'll get arms--
it was the Iran Contra affair--
you'll get arms from us.
They were then at war with Iraq.
Saddam Hussein had invaded them.
That's never been proven.
I want to make it absolutely
clear, it's never been proven.
There were congressional
hearings about it.
What we do know is that his
vice presidential running
mate, George H.W. Bush, went
to Paris during the campaign.
I don't know that there
are a lot of votes there.
His campaign manager
went to Mexico.
Was this part of a scheme?
We don't know.
What I do know is this.
It made a huge difference.
And just imagine this, two
things from '80 campaign,
I have to tell you.
We made the huge
political mistake
of having one debate with Reagan
eight days before the election.
Never do that when
you're an incumbent.
Reagan's a great debater.
But in my interview
with James Baker
for this book, his
campaign manager,
he admitted that
they stole the debate
book I'd prepared Carter,
with all of the attack lines,
and so forth.
He said, our campaign
manager put the thing
on my door about two
weeks before the campaign,
and said, Jim, you might
want to look at this.
And he says to me, I thought
for a second or two about
whether I'm dealing
with stolen goods.
But it only took a second to
decide I was going to read it.
Was it decisive?
Maybe not.
But I sure would have liked
to have had their debate book.
But now Iran, OK?
So we lost in a landslide.
Before the debate, we're ahead.
We lose the debate.
But debates have a half
life of a couple of days.
So the Saturday before
the Tuesday election--
I'm not talking about
our own internal polls--
CBS, NBC have us
even and advancing.
And it looks like we're
going to pull off.
I'm in the Chicago Hilton Hotel,
at the airport, because we're
campaigning there.
And I get a call at 3:00
o'clock in the morning.
Air Force One is going
to leave in 45 minutes.
The president's going
back to Washington.
I said, why are we leaving?
The Iranians have
made another offer.
I begged Carter not to go back.
I said, just read the offer.
It was a positive
step, but not enough.
He, instead, went back.
It reignited the
whole hostage thing.
It was not sufficient.
And we dropped like a rock.
So what was it like?
Our last-- every president
or presidential campaign
does this.
The last day of the
election, you go east to west
to follow the setting sun.
And you end up in California.
We ended up, in
this case, actually,
in a Boeing hangar in Seattle.
They
Were not making the X 8s,
by the way, at that time.
And we come back.
We get on Air Force One.
And Pat Caddell, our pollster,
calls and says, it's all over.
The Iran thing has come back.
We're dropping like a rock.
Of course, he tells Carter.
Carter comes out.
And I have to admit,
I'm crying like a baby.
I hugged him.
And I said, we've let you down.
And he said, no, you
haven't let me down.
We land in Warner
Robins, Dakota Plains--
mind you, this is the
way modern politics are.
The first vote
hasn't been cast yet.
But we knew we'd lost
because of the polls.
Rosalynn is crying,
has to hide herself.
It was an extremely emotional
way to end a presidency.
And that's the way
Carter is remembered,
for losing overwhelmingly.
And that's why I
wrote this book.
Because there's so
much that occurred
between the time he took the
oath of office and the time
he left.
So much was done that we
benefit from today that I want
that full picture to be out.
And I want everyone
to hear it and see it.
MEREDITH EVANS:
So, yes or no, was
there a relationship
between Carter and Reagan,
knowing that that
emotional loss--
STUART EIZENSTAT: OK.
The answer is no,
with one exception,
and that is, the
hostages are released.
Reagan is day one
of his presidency.
In a gracious act, he has
Carter go on Air Force One
to get the hostages in Germany.
Now, interestingly, he and
Ford have a bitter campaign.
I mean, again, we won by a 1/2
of 1%, by 30 electoral votes.
And there was no
relationship there.
Two things happened to cause
a beautiful relationship
to happen.
The first is, Golda Meyer
dies, former prime minister
of Israel.
And Reagan asks the
three living presidents--
I have a picture in my
office, the three of of them--
Nixon, Ford, and Carter
to go on Air Force One.
So the seating on Air Force
One, as they go to Israel,
is Carter and Ford are
sitting next to each other.
And then there's a aisle.
And Nixon is on the other side.
And he's brooding
the whole time.
And Ford had no
great love for him.
And Carter and Ford bond
during this 12-hour trip
back and forth.
They did joint things at
their presidential libraries.
And I created, with
his domestic advisor,
Jim Cannon something called
the American Agenda, which
they co-chaired, which
had a bipartisan group
to give advice to whoever was
elected in '88, it was Ford.
That was still when
bipartisanship was possible.
So we went to Beaver
Creek, where his place.
We went to the Carter Center.
They had a beautiful
relationship.
MEREDITH EVANS: So on that
note, beautiful relationships,
with happy thoughts, we're
going to end our conversation
with Mr. Eizenstat.
[APPLAUSE]
STUART EIZENSTAT:
Talk about books.
MEREDITH EVANS: They're here.
His book is a fabulous read.
I love it.
It's done with archival
materials and his own work.
And they're available.
STUART EIZENSTAT: And
I'm signing books after--
MEREDITH EVANS:
And he's signing.